an appeals court has ruled that
President Trump has to pay twenty five
million dollars to Trump University
students
Trump's not lying when he says graduates
of Trump University make a lot of money
mercedes-benz caused some controversy so
now they've apologized mercedes-benz has
apologized for quoting the Dalai Lama in
its advertising yeah and Ford apologized
for claiming the Dalai Lama will be
reincarnated as a Ford Mustang that
firmly that's not gonna happen
Oh as promised feel free to laugh or not
laugh just mad you missed that big four
thousand show aren't yet then you take
it out on me huh I'm in that stock
market what a wild ride folks what's
this guy what is that all about look
like I'm being electrocuted
due to this week's stock market plunge
Warren Buffett personally lost five
billion dollars yeah then he stuck a
hand in his sofa cushions and said never
mind got it
found it's right here
anyway my mic fell off I'm being told
this has never happened in 25 years my
mic fell off so did you hear any of that
that just happened right now yeah cuz it
wasn't that good let's change the
subject
yeah but something sure I can feel that
cold getting better already
you